MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this last example of
relativistic kinematics,
we want to investigate
scattering--
in this specific
case, a scattering
of a photon on an
electron at rest.
So we have as an initial state
a photon, an electron at rest,
and then the photon is
scattered and we also
observe a scattered electron.
There's one important
piece of physics
here, which we add without
further explanation, which
is the Planck-Einstein
relation, which
relates the energy of the photon
to the frequency of the photon
or the wavelength.
This is fundamentally
important in quantum physics,
and can be explained or tested
with the photoelectric effect
for which Einstein
received the Nobel Prize.
So what we want to do here
is find the wavelength shift,
so delta lambda, which
is the wavelength
of the incoming photon
minus the wavelength
of the outgoing photon, as
a function of the scattering
angle zeta, as shown
in this picture here.
OK, so again, this
is an activity
I want you to work on
and try to find out this.
The algebra here is not
trivial, but knowing
how to set up a problem
like this is important.
So let's try.
So the way to set this up
is to write this four vector
relation, or you could
just simply write down
energy conservation and
momentum conservation.
So you have an initial
state, the before,
and the final state,
the after, where
you simply add the four
vectors of the initial electron
and photon and set this equal
to the scattered electron
and scattered photon.
Now, we are interested
in a quantity delta
lambda, which is related to the
change in energy of the photon.
So therefore, it brings
the four vector of the four
scattered photon over
here to this side,
and builds a square,
which allows us then
to use our invariant information
in the scattering process.
When we explore
the squared here,
we find the photon
four vectors squared
for the scattered and
the unscattered photon,
minus 2 times the product
of the two four vectors.
Now, the mass of
the photon is 0,
and then hence
the invariant mass
is 0, too, so this
invariant four vector is 0.
So this cancels
and this cancels.
And then we know that
the mass of the electron
is the mass of the electron,
the initial momentum
of the electron is 0, and
we just for the further,
not to get confused,
we said C equal to 1.
So then we just go through
a sequence of algebra
here, making use of information
that those guys here are simply
the mass of the electron.
And we move things
around a little bit
and then find this
equation here,
which relates the energies
of the two photons
[INAUDIBLE] the
scattering angle, which
we get from the scattered
product of the [? three ?]
momentum of the photon
to the change in electron
energy, which is the energy of
the electron minus the mass.
OK.
And then we start using
the Einstein relation here.
And again, a little
bit of algebra
then brings us to delta
lambda equal h over me
times 1 minus cosine theta.
So this relates the
shift in wavelengths
to the scattering
angle of the photon.
Important.
If you want to recall this,
the most important part
through this problem is setting
up this first equation here,
which relates the
energy and the momentum,
or the four vector
of those particles,
before and after the collision.
And again, then it takes
a little bit of practice.
But the way to approach
most of this problem
is to make use of the
invariant four vector squared,
or the invariant mass
of the objects involved,
if we know the masses
of the object involved.
OK.